vanno bene
sono stati oggi a grandissima richiesta
torna l'ascensore e pauroso ma questa
volta giocheremo all'ascensore pauroso 2
cioè in questo senso lo incontriamo
tantissimi personaggi cattivi non
sopravvivere più livelli possibile ri a
busto privi a più livelli vince se non
avete visto rilascio in tour poroso
numero 1 andate a vederlo lì a poco
detto video per scoprire che cattivo
siete voi gioco dei mi piace la non vi
piacciono cifra da cosa mi piace
corrisponde al vostro personaggio quindi
clean
scrivete se volete dei commenti che
personaggio cattivo e siete alla fine
del video potrete scrivere qual è stato
il personaggio più foro secondo voi chi
penserà vitale o amici ma passiamo
all'outfit di oggi al lilla e kiev e che
cosa abbiamo il fiorire non forieri la
un po ma i nostri personaggi ho messo un
vestito viola è bello cerchietto con il
corpo da unicorno invece vitale ha
sempre la maglietta giornale però tempo
più colorate se io presto qualche colore
dopo averne ho tolto il cappello garanti
arriviamo subito voi mettetevi comodi
preti pop corn e se non mi seguite
ancora integra mandate a seguirmi
entriamo primo cattivo di credito fretta
ma fu di pelè riconosciuto tutto scritto
dvd basi però io volevo farmi fare tutto
la testa siamo qui insieme
non credo che c'è anche chucky qua
guarda lì ci sta aspettando la sotto
meglio non sender and then o meglio
aspettare se guardate il secondo tutti è
entrato dentro l'ascensore guarda agli
minuto con uno tra l'altro queste sono
tutte le scatole con chuck i quindici
sono tantissimi ma possiamo sempre dire
che questo sensore numero 2 sembra un
pochino più colori 1 abbiamo fatto 100
punti finora il prossimo livello e
allora sia un motivo in una in una
fattoria quasi solo delle mani
io stesso mi voglio avvicinare la porta
[Musica]
5 dante nascondo che qualcosa di gigante
sentito così che deve tantissimo aiuto
quella bocciata
mio marito mi ha fatto male io io mi
sono aspetta qua perché non mi sei io
non ci vedo entrato di trovarsi si sono
scappati sono stati d'aiuto per fortuna
sembra abbastanza nell'ascensore
per fortuna sembra abbastanza lento meno
male che rende un ritornello aiuto no no
io sopra visto giusto il tempo per un
pelo
tenendo bruno verso di merce un tot di
tempo in cui bisogna cercare di
sopravvivere se faccio un esempio oggi
piatto al prossimo livello abbiamo già
150 punti allora ma tipo una sala di
registrazione della tv 32 minuti che può
essere cattivo
mi sembra tutto molto ok il no c'è
qualcuno con arancia rossa questo
pensionato previsto e punito con una
mazza rosso o capitolo 1 di snow white
night 3d
io sono sulla scrivania attenta che noi
a catona l'ascensore ma a me sto
benissimo qui sulla scrivania ha
eliminato qualcuna delle strade dello
sponsor ma perché questa musica
rilassante ma questo è stato facile
i 200 punti trattiva infatti tutti
andiamo a finance smedins riconosco
lavori ovvero hanno delle telecamere
uffici un pezzo di pizza hai visto dove
dobbiamo andare non sta andando con sono
infatti stavo seguendo qualcun altro ma
ora sono tutt ora ci sono io me lo dite
ma che succede perché supera ora non ho
visto su scappando ma qui sembra tutto
finito è enorme ma facciamo queste cose
appese ai muri dei pezzi di pizza si può
uscire tesi finita eccoti ma almeno non
sono da storico vanta ben cassino non ci
ha messo notte
ci sono le telecamere importante scopo
sono un po cosa un po non so se posso
risalita e diamo prova c'è un ascensore
ha eliminato tutti no io sono ancora qui
dove ho dentro ancora nell'ascensore per
una sorta eliminando tutti qui abbiamo
perso tutto perché fosse dentro
all'ascensore ma risaliamo e riproviamo
guerra siamo un altro piano ad essere
matti e monete le monete fine il cattivo
qua rischio di che cos'è questa stanza a
qualcuno mi ha appena preso sono master
lorenzo grant e san marcello gigante con
un martello gigante mi è sembrato che
comprendesse eccolo questo qui
risaliamo preghiamo il signore diamo un
po chi è il cattivo qua potrebbe essere
baby glielo ok
ma guarda tu statuto lion non ci sono
mai stati come dietro l'angolo e
nell'ascensore adesso le apu da non
entrare dentro la sebbene sono più
riuscito compenso di rete ad arrivare
qua dietro ok lei è ancora in ascensore
aspettiamo quarta uscendo però mi sarà
ok ottimo livello
ti amo in minecraft per crediti si è
quindi chi è il cattivo di minecraft ho
sentito un rumore 30
che cos'è potremmo detto sta
raccogliendo vita un altro gigante e poi
scappa scappa dal segno meno santo
dietro l'altro gigante si sia uno di
mike phillips
io sono nascoste dietro l'albero stimolo
migliore per adottare un albero sono
dentro la bear ubicata l'albero si forse
funziona vediamo eliminato vino ha fatto
volare qualcuno eri tu usi a un amico
tra l'altro è la vimark primi noto è
difficilissimo questo sta eliminando
tutti sono reattore sono tutti lì io
sono 354 punti e tu a 316 stanno in
vantaggio un'ottima cosa è cosa
c'è uno slide per terra e che cambia
velocemente a salendo il pavimento vedi
matt attori sono bravissimi a fare i bar
con ho visto spiaccicato mille volte a 9
a notarlo sarà difficilissimo salita
profondamente il pavimento la forza
dell'ascensore diventata di slime e
adesso come facciamo ad uscire siamo
intrappolati dentro l'ascensore si può
premiamo bruciante è un successo
ok si sono chiuse fra pesa l'ombra di un
brutto presenti invece poi lavorare con
i piatti fa entrare
un cazzo però qui il pagliaccio
guardarsi sì l'ho visto ho visto adesso
si vuole uscire a immortalò jinyan dove
mi nascondo io salgo perché non mi pesa
diventato anche un pisolino dov'è il
discorso di recco lo aiutavano a che
fare con spiaccicare ho fatto che siamo
sopravvissuti alla pagnotta uno dei più
di paura però col martello gigante tra
cos'è una mappa di più sul 20 ha preso
qualcuno ha preso quel numero verde
poverino è il e ora che succede meglio
spostarsi dalle entrate sarà decisa e
gay era cambio di nuovo a superare la
mano anch'io voglio salire quando si è
fatto di temi così se non fossi riuscito
sotto di quanto neppure effettivamente
un buon è un buon punto quando bisogna
scappare talenti prossimo a livello
cos'è questo stiamo si sta rompendo non
c'erano tre serate m l'uscita è uscita
attento in uscita è piaciuto aiuto aiuto
nell'ascensore nell'ascensore che il non
entrerò più nella sensore devo dire che
supercar in e così per me una bambolina
cari quando vedi si stanno salvando
perché si sono messi al soprano kg e
basta quindi non li raggiunge perché
piccolina e carina e paurosa insieme se
farò molto inquietante come ha rotto il
vetro ed è uscita dal vetro si fossero
molto semplice presti ma livello un
carro armato che stai attento a non
mettersi troppo vicino a quel carro
armato perché sarà il cattivo quando si
attesto prego qui da noi perché si
scivola sul carro armato è vero che ti
fa vedere giu
che cosa nell'ascensore attenta che
dovevi mettere tanto quindi ed io sono
nascosto dietro il carro armato che ci
sono anch'io quella brava sta andando
ma dov'è lo vedi e ancora la scienza o
non mi spingerà più non hanno più dubbi
spingerlo fuori dal carro armato
sopravvissuti ecco l'ultimo livello ci
sono delle sirene
chi sarà il cattivo qua qui c'è un
pulsante rosso ma sembra lato non siamo
che cosa è
non vedo niente aiuta tu mi conosce per
questo cattivo è un tipo duro con una
busta in testa è nata qui si può
scendere guarda ci sono le scale
forse è meglio non passerei ma guarda è
la giudica timonov e di tipo qualcuno di
fare meta francese lo so voi lo
conoscete come si chiama questo cattivo
per fortuna non si muove allora io me ne
tornerà sotto retata vantaggioso e lui
il cattivo c massimo livello
né tutto bene che cos'è questa aspetta
dio mi sposterei va meglio a spostarsi
arriverà qualcosa quando il problema che
cosa ne è uscito qualcuno anche sull'uso
no ok a questo era semplicissimo la
prossima
l'attenzione è su di morale non fa
entrare qua no ma chi rilascia le banane
per terra ma c'è qualcuno che non lo so
se avevo un cookie
ma come si chiama questo cattivo e
ditelo voi inquietante bene quanti punti
abbiamo fatto io ho fatto 710 punti io
ho 668 ma noi scritto b intraneità avete
indovinato
non è che facciamo un altro episodio
della sono stato bene mi piace erano
andate a vedere la prima parte perché
super divertente oppure cliccate in un
altro di queste 3 castellini 4 attaccate
su quella che preferite
[Musica]